اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه سيطره الكامله
لقواتها على بلده سول الواقعه قرب سوليدار
وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايفور
كوناشينكو ان القوات الروسيه قضت خلال 24
ساعه الماضيه على اكثر من 90 جنديا
اوكرانيا ودمرت اليات عسكريه ومستودعا
للذخيره
من الوحدات
من نارين من وحدات الطيران الروسي وقوات
الصواريخ والمدفعيه في المنطقه الجنوبيه
وخلال 24 ساعه تم القضاء على 90 جنديا
اوكرانيا وتدمير مستودع ذخيره لرجمات
قواتنا الجويه
25 تابعه للقوات الجويه الاخرانيه قرب
قريته في جمهوريه الشعبيه وتم تدميره
مستودع ذخيره لرجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه قرب مدينه اكرام تورس
هو
كويستها قالت هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
الجهود الروسيه منصبه الان علشان هجوم
واسع على مدينه بخموت واضافت الهيئه في
بيانها انها احبطت هجمات عده شنت باتجاه
المدينه واخرى على افديك ومناطق متفرقه من
شرق اقليم دوباس واشارت الهيئه الى ان
السلاح الجو الاوكراني نفذ غارات استهدفت
مراكز تجمع عند القوات الروسيه في مدينه
سوليدار وفي عدد بل وعدد من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي التابعه
الينا عمر الحاج عمر اذن ماذا تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه حول اعلان
الدفاع الروسيه بانها تسيطر على مزيد من
المناطق باتجاه ضخمات
[موسيقى]
نعم جلال الروايه الاوكرانيه لم تتغير
كثيرا منذ بدايه الحمله العسكريه الروسيه
على مدينه سوريا حتى الان القوات
الاوكرانيه فيما يخص السوري على الاقل ما
تزال تقول ان القوات الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تقاتل في تلك المدينه وان
القوات الروسيه لا تسيطروا على كامل مدينه
سردار وان كان في هذا اشاره او اعتراف
ضميني بوجود القوات الروسيه في المدينه بل
هو سيطرتها على جزء منها في ما يخص
المناطق الاخرى على القوات الاوكرانيه
الناطق باسم العمليات العسكريه في المنطقه
الشرقيه لم يعلق حتى الان على هذه الاخبار
بل التزم كما ذكرت بالروايه التي تتحدث عن
استمرار المعارك في تلك الجبهه ولكن جلال
هنا نستطيع القول اننا رصدنا الكثير من
التعزات العسكريه والحركه همم غير
الاعتياديه في المنطقه سواء في همم
ترامادول في العاصمه المؤقته او حتى في
المدن القريبه من باخ مو هناك الكثير من
التعزات العسكريه
كانت تساقط الى تلك المنطقه الى مدينه
باخبط بالتحديد اضافه الى الصيانه دورات
صيانه لبعض الاليات ورسالها مره اخرى وفقا
للقاده الميدانيين الذين تحدثنا عنهم فيما
يشير الى
ربما استعدادات اوكرانيه جديه وحساسه
لهجوم كبير قد تشهده مدينه القوات
الاوكرانيه
والمشاهداتنا على الاقل ما تزال تسيطر على
الطرق الواصله بين ضخمه وبين باقي المناطق
التي تخضع لسيطره القوات الاوكرانيه هنا
في مقاطعه دنيا وفي هذا ربما نقض للروايه
الروسيه تتحدث عن حصار على المدينه
الاوكرانيه ايضا بثت كثيرا من الصور هيئه
الاركان تتحدث عن تصديها لقوات الروسيه
التي كانت تحاول عمر التقدم في هذا
الاتجاه وحتى استهدافها لقوات الروسيه في
سوريا
في هذه المرحله على على ضخمه هل لك ان
تطلعنا على اهميتها الميدانيه بنسبه
للطرفين
بالاشك جلال مدينه محمود مدينه مهمه جدا
بالنسبه لكلى الجانبين بعجال السيطره على
باخموسه يعني بطبيعه الحال بدايه فصلي
مناطق سيطره القوات الاوكرانيه شمال مقاطع
عن المناطق الجنوبيه وهذا سيتعزز اكثر في
ظل وجود قوات الروسيه في مدينه سردار فان
المناطق ابتداء من سوريا
كلها الواقع في جنوب الاقليم عن المناطق
همم وبندق همم
الواقعه في الشمال هذا يعني همم حسنا
المناطق الجنوبيه التي تعاني اصلا من
هجمات روسيه وتهديد العاصمه الاداريه كما
ذكرت همم اكرمته الحقيقه القوات الروسيه
لها افضليه في هذا الاتجاه بعجال اقول
لانها تسيطر على هذا تحليق طيران الحربي
الاوكراني بالمناسبه باتجاه باخمد هذا في
هذا الاتجاه لان هناك
دور كبير العبه هذا الطيران في استاد
القوات في تلك المنطقه
نعم الصوت واضح تماما نعم جلال كنت اتحدث
عن افضليه القوات الروسيه ذلك انها سيطرت
في وقت سابق على روبيجنا واعلى بوبوسنا
وهذه مناطق المتصله
بمقاطعته همم تشكل حزاما قويا المتقدمه
للقوات الروسيه بالسيطره على ضخمه تم هذا
السيناريو فكما ذكر ستعزل المناطق
الجنوبيه وربما سيمهد لسقوطها بيدها
القوات الروسيه شكرا لك عمر فيك
[موسيقى]